as podcast has bad words hmm hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 128 today
we're gonna talk about what Ryan
resetting or healing in a way recharging
healing yeah all those things yeah I
mean the way hovering from tour yeah
this is like the you know the initial
use of the word recovery meaning to like
literally recover what you and I have
spent the last 12 months on the road and
I say you and I Josh we've spent the
last eight years on the road we're both
right then right but this is actually
the last tour right yeah I think so
Vince that will do it last bit of on the
road we're gonna do the rest of this
year yeah and and there might be an
event or two out there but we're
certainly not gonna do any prolonged
touring and I talked about this on the
intro to the last episode just briefly
you know for me the thing that I've
learned is we've done this is our eighth
year and we've basically done eight
tours and in those eight years right and
in doing that we we've done short tours
long tours five of those eight were like
these really protracted tours like this
last one was a year long 50 cities the
one in twenty fourteen hundred cities
hundred and nineteen events that one was
even more grueling in a way but in some
instances it was actually less grueling
for a bunch of different reasons and
there are other times we've gone on the
road for you the very first tour we did
was like nine months where we did 33
cities we'd go out for you know gigs
yeah or two weeks or whatever and I
found that like for me the sweet spot is
like if we decide to do another tour in
the future it's gotta be a week two
weeks mass it can't be a year and it
can't be you know this year either like
I just just pausing and taking this time
to recover because I get really excited
about about
touring but by the end of it I'm like
exhausted and I'm ready to say okay I
want to focus on something else I would
not I would I don't want to be exhausted
any other way man I mean the whole tour
was was awesome like Mariah was able to
be there with me the whole time the the
the audience was awesome it was great
getting out and meeting our new readers
and our new supporters yeah because it
was it was a lot of new folks just
because of the documentary right yeah I
guess it's my way of saying like yes I
am exhausted as hell mm-hmm
but I am very delightfully exhausted
yeah well and here's the other thing so
I was I heard the stat yesterday Ryan
and it made me think of how we use our
resources last year and that reach our
most precious resources are our time and
our attention but the companies use year
after year they'll use 90 percent of
their resources on the same thing that
they did last year so you think of some
corporation they say okay we have a
hundred million dollars we're gonna
spend ninety million dollars the same
exact way this year as we did last year
but yours and my most precious resource
is our time it's not the money that we
make and so we have a certain amount of
time that we can spin this year and the
question is do we go out and do another
50 cities again no like it doesn't make
sense to keep using your resources the
same way if you want to be innovative
and I actually think that going out for
a year and doing a tour well it's really
rewarding we get to touch a lot of
people I have a lot of meaningful
conversations now the question is how
can i how configu tively speaking we
touch them now we give hugs lots of hugs
do you not touch people when you hug
them well I didn't really do the hug
lines this time so you've done a hug
line every single event we have oh yeah
that is true we did we did do hug lines
this one it wasn't the typical hug line
but we did we did the pre-show VIP event
well you're talking physically and
figuratively speaking yeah
yeah and and I guess my point is here is
that I don't want to keep using the
resources that I have this this time
that I have the same way I think it's
productive to do something else with it
and I'm really enjoying getting back
into this this root this creative not
routine routine is the wrong word
creative habits is is the better were
writing and then also we're working on
this this documentary and then
podcasting to me that's the three-legged
table or I think we can provide the most
value to other people's lives the
touring helps in one way it gets the
message out in a different way but in in
Torme in terms of using those resources
a way to reach the most people is for us
to do this we're behind these
microphones right now we're in our
beautiful new studio space thank you to
our patreon supporters for this this
space here in Los Angeles we finally got
this new table and Ryan saw it for the
first time today he walked in here he
goes oh my god I think we're legit now
yeah we have a drink we have an actual
human I can't wait to give our our
patrons our patronage 'as a patron
patrons yeah are you patronizing them I
cannot wait to give them a tour of this
space they're gonna love it yeah we'll
do it we'll do a video tour we got a
couple small things we need to button up
first and eventually we're gonna do a
video version of the podcast as well so
you can subscribe to our YouTube channel
over it
youtube.com slash the minimalists and we
will do a video a version of this once
we have enough patreon supporters for
that Ryan I really felt like we've so
this is episode 128 I feel like we've
we've really hit a stride since episode
of 100 for me but especially in the last
few episodes I was going back this
weekend and Liz awesome listening so you
feel like you know what you're doing I
still don't I still feel like I don't
know what I'm doing I don't know that I
know what I'm doing but I know one of us
is confident in this podcast I feel
really good about the conversations that
you and I have had so we did an episode
on quality recently it was episode 126
loved that episode 123 with Paul Johnson
the hobbies podcast which you we called
it hobbies and we talked about hobbies
but you really could have called that
one career
activity it was really about creating in
a way that's what my favorite
conversations we've ever had and it was
a crazy long podcast but like we had the
most meaningful conversation just
sitting here with Paul from Canyon City
and and and just talking about about
what it meant to produce meaningful
creations not content generation but
producing meaningful creations and an
episode 122 we talked about been trying
so hard to not use the c-word content oh
yeah I don't it's like the worst C word
in my vernacular there were seven letter
word in the English language that's
right yeah um but no it's every time I
catch myself I was saying it the other
day I'm like I know I was like oh yeah
to Amenti I'm like you know you've got a
um you know if you want to put content
up then you got to focus and I'm like
wait a minute let's just let's just talk
about content for a second and here's
the thing it's it's a it's a sort of a
moral term like it's not inherently bad
but but it has become that it's become
vapid within the everyday vernacular and
people think of like me I think of that
there are people out there putting out
podcasts putting out 3 podcast episodes
a week just saying get more content out
there and it's okay to make three
podcast episodes a week if they're good
it's great to do it every single day if
you're good at that but if you're doing
it just to generate more content to help
you out in the numbers game then it
actually waters down what your creation
your what your creations are and it
makes them less meaningful
right if you're doing it just to create
more for the sake of creating more it
actually gets in the way of what you're
trying to accomplish I think and so we
sort of had a conversation about that we
had a few other conversations one is
about how we're using social media this
year I really enjoyed that but that
episode that was episode 120 ever sowed
119 we talked about decorating and 118
we talked about collecting and those
were like the perfect sort of combo
together talking about collecting things
and then also how we sort of the
aesthetics of home life so decorating
and then most recently we had that
conversation with Derek Siver's in New
Zealand and man I remember enjoying the
you know I don't listen to any of my
podcast well yeah I mean was it was it
good now yeah it was it was better than
I remembered it like I remember really
enjoying it because Sean produces it
it's always gonna be better than what we
remember it because podcast Sean does a
great job of making us sound awesome he
puts a like a sheen on top of it he
corrects our spelling mistakes in the
podcast yeah and and put that
conversation with Derek was so good and
I got text messages from friends who
were like that's the best podcast you've
done in a long time and oh nice
yeah it was it was really good and so
there's there's a lot out there if you
want to go back and check out the rub
belt one man that's like all the
religion one that's like one of my
that's the one I got a bunch of texts on
well especially from just some friends
who I grew up religious with so it was
it was it was nice to get feedback from
them to know that you know that that it
helped them out that's because the
conversation totally helped me out like
I had a blast yeah and I really hoped
away with with a lot from that
conversation I'm glad other people could
get something out of it too yeah I
talked way too much during that episode
I listened to it and I'm like it was
really good and I wish I I could have
just shut up more but when I think the
conversations we had especially the
conversations you had with Rob or were
really meaningful and I got a few texts
from from people in their life Wow I
knew that you guys had a bit of a
religious background and had different
religious beliefs but it was really good
to hear you dive into it without any
Dogma but being willing to discuss
spirituality and religion especially
with someone like Rob who has changed
quite a bit in fact I read a book
recently Ryan do you know who Kent
Dobson is so speaking of Rob Bell so
Kent Dobson's father his he's a guy
named Edie Dobson he was sort of Rob
bells mentor Oh Edie
it was Rob's mentor and then his son
Kent actually took over Mars Hill after
Rob laughs
and he soon left shortly after that he
wrote a book about about his journey
with spirituality and it was like you
wrote the book
honestly it was it reminded me of your
journey with religion and spirituality
it's called bitten by a camel and it's a
really short read I would encourage you
to read it I read it in a day and he
should be saving this for the
value-added portion no I've got some
really good stuff on talking about oh
yeah in fact you and I were talking on
the phone yesterday and I'm like oh I
gotta shut up cuz there's some stuff I
want to talk to you about on the podcast
I know it is some stuff that I want to
recommend todaiji Schumann's so just so
our audience members know Josh and I we
will avoid having conversations away
from the mics so we can have genuine
conversations for you all who are
listening to this yeah because we don't
want to like just rehash everything
sometimes I'll say hey let's save that
for the podcast but um this book bitten
by a camel right it was like his journey
into like you know conservative
Christianity and then like more walking
toward the edges and then walking beyond
the edges and really changing the
vernacular he used he wouldn't even I
don't he wouldn't call himself a
Christian anymore but he would he talks
about religion and he talks about God
and he even talks about how the word God
has become so like weighed down in a way
and it really reminded me of your
journey with religion I mean there were
a lot of parallels I was reading I'm
like yeah this is this is something that
Ryan would would really identify with as
much as you identified with Rob when he
was seated right here you would identify
even more in fact if he's if Kenton is
back in Los Angeles and probably loved
to sit down and thought to him - I think
you'd find a ton of value and in that
conversation who ought to text me a link
or something yeah I will the the book is
called a road I can't notes and and he
did a recent podcast episode with with
Pete Holmes cool so Pete Holmes who was
in that heretic documentary that we
talked to rob eval he he's the comedian
who's on crashing and he was on his
podcast and it was was a solid
conversation so you can check that out
as well and so yeah we're we're done
for a while and we're getting back into
some certain habits too today and this
week and this month and this year and I
don't know about you I was talking to
podcast Sean before this started and for
me it's just been about like it's really
hard for me to write on the road I'd do
it intermittently but it's hard for me
to write it period and then you throw
another factor in there and then it's
like really hard for me to write well
actually what I should say is it's
really easy for me to not write it's
actually hard for me to not write that's
fast it's hard on you yet what no it's
hot it's hard on me too that's true but
like I feel compelled or propelled by
the active of creating in a way that
it's like it fuels me it's like it's
hard for me to not put gas in the car
because I also realize like that's what
propels the car forward right
anyway let's let's dive into some some
questions we have here because I want to
talk to you Ryan about some of the
habits that I'm trying to the the
reclamation of my habits and the
reclamation of a of a lifestyle or maybe
even just a new life now that we're here
in Los Angeles I was talking to our
accountant yesterday and work you know
it's it's tax season in fact this comes
out on on the official tax day I believe
and I was like man I don't think I've
spent more than like a week and a half
at a time in Los Angeles no since we
quote moved here how's LA I'm like I
don't know like I mean if I feel like
I'm on vacation in LA a great place to
visit repeatedly right but now that
we're back here it's like I'm I'm
falling in love with with the city and
we're actually gonna have an opportunity
to do that this week into we're doing a
coffee crawl and some other really cool
stuff that I think maybe you and I can
can talk about but let's go ahead and
dive into these questions our first
question is from Jason and Sacramento in
light of you guys journey out of the
corporate world and into the middleman
the minimalist project and also in light
of the break you're taking right now
and Joshua's situation I'd be curious to
hear you guys feedback on the role that
you think minimalism
and intentional living can play in
healing various types of healing whether
that be physical healing or
psychological and emotional healing or
some other type of healing because I
feel like for me minimalism has played a
role in healing of various tides I never
really thought about minimalism healing
until this question yes it and like even
looking at it from that perspective I
really had to kind of dig deep to think
about like how does minimalism heal
someone like I don't because when I
think of my journey I don't I mean I'd
be interested to hear your thoughts but
like when I think about when you
introduce minimalism to me when I
started applying this to my life I
didn't really feel like I was being
healed as much as I was being redirected
right if that makes sense
I don't know what do you think why me I
think at our events when you go around
place your hands on people and heal them
of their ailments wasn't healed people
Jesus Christ yeah pun intended like no I
mean seriously do you feel like like
when you heard this question were you
like oh yeah like I can totally talk
about how minimalism has healed do but
but but in a way that's different
how minimalism has provided time for
healing
so leads to the providing of the time
and the question is then time for what
right maybe it's time for healing maybe
it's time for relationships and maybe
it's time for creativity it's time to to
consume less so I I can do something
else with that time and and for me part
of that is is the healing you'll
remember back in well we can actually
talk about my last decade real quick I
can I can sum it up so I'll be 37 really
soon so over the last decade I've had a
lot of health issues it sort of started
when I was 27
and I had plenty of health issues before
then but my body was just you know
tolerating my abuse for a very long time
this is Matt Nathanson line the
singer-songwriter Matt Nathanson yeah he
is the song on his second two most
recent album the album is called the
last of the great pretenders but the
first song on there at the very first
line of the first song on that album is
I'd kill anyone who treats you as bad as
I do and it's like it's about like being
a crappy husband or boyfriend or
whatever but it's also true about myself
I was thinking about this this morning
like there's that there were times where
I treated myself so bad my body so
poorly that I don't want to even be a
friend of the person who treats me as
bad as I do well dude let's talk about
that what what cuz when I think about
how you used to be ten years ago versus
now I mean I guess you were eating
you're eating like [ __ ] maybe yeah yeah
drinking a million cups of coffee a day
literally 20 cups of coffee a day
operating on probably not as much sleep
as what you're operating on now four
hours of sleep a night most night yeah
and I require less sleep than most
people I think like I probably got three
hours last night but that was a that was
because it was so windy here like it was
it was crazy yeah but anyway I the the
problem is and by the way most nights I
don't recommend three hours of sleep
even for myself I probably get six or
seven hours most nights
eight if I can if I my body allows me to
sleep you and I are in the same boat we
can get to sleep like that mm-hmm but
staying asleep is the home to bed at
9:30 p.m. last night
uh-huh I got up at 5:00 a.m. in like
there was no yeah my body would not let
me go back to sleep yeah and I was like
all right well let's get up and start
the day you you and I are in the same
space there and then our partners are in
the same space as well like they have
such a hard time getting the sleep so
mariah has told me you should when she's
with you like Ryan I'll just fall right
asleep but I I takes me forever but then
they can sleep in and I'm like oh
it's yeah and especially like this
morning when I got up at 5 a.m. I
totally woke Mariah up and she was like
oh what time is it I'm like it's 5:00
I'm getting up and she was like oh okay
and then like went right back to sleep
yeah anyway so I I grew up with a really
unhealthy diet and and I was morbidly
obese I mean literally morbidly obese
you know this because you were you were
certainly obese as a kid I think I was
the morbid half of the dress it right if
there was one obese person and one who
was morbidly obese yeah you were
definitely fatter than so so fat and and
and that carried those habits even I
lost the weight in high school but then
I gained it all back in my early 20s I
wasn't as fat as I was when I was 12
although I weighed the same I weighed
about 240 and we got told in my 20s you
got taller yeah that's true a little bit
more yeah yeah but I even waiting to I'm
165 now probably but I weigh 240 and I
wasn't just fat I felt like crap and and
there there became the spiral out of
that I developed chemical sensitivities
and I think that's because I screwed my
gut up in my 20s I took a supposedly
benign antibiotic for a very long time
it was 5 is really bad scalp acne and so
I took this this antibiotic supposed to
be found but it killed my gut microbiome
gave me c-diff which kills 14 thousand
people a year and from that spiraled a
whole bunch of other problems I my
hormones were out of whack so I was
getting a lot of back pain because I
wasn't producing enough growth hormone
and my other hormones were out of whack
as well and so the back pain the gut
pain the chemical sensitivities the
seasonal allergies that were just
debilitating like but they got to a
point with the seasonal allergies where
I would have to like just lay in bed I
couldn't do anything it was that bad
yeah I remember man and and so I
developed all of these ailments that
that continued and even got worse into
my 30s even though I was living a better
lifestyle and I hadn't I I had done so
much damage and so yeah I'd kill anyone
who treats
as bad as my previous self treats me I
don't want to be friends with that guy
right I treated myself so poorly part of
that is because I just didn't know I
didn't know that gluten and dairy were
terrible for me personally they're not
bad for everyone my partner Rebecca eats
cheese sandwiches and she's the fittest
person I know
yeah oh that was just sorry I was just
gonna say no did I give that analogy of
I don't want to be friends with that
person and I'd never even thought of it
that way dude I would totally be friends
with myself anyway
no yeah I would not want to be friends
with my 25 year old so right yes I be
friends with your current self right
yeah I I i could definitely be friends
with my current self because my current
self would leave me alone he wouldn't
want to spend time with anyone else
yeah but but there has been a lot of
room for healing the last decade
especially the last five years and
especially the last two and a half years
for me we had to take a break from
podcasting a couple years ago October
2016 and we took a month or two break
because there we got to a point where I
thought like oh man maybe I'm dying I
can't figure out what my problems are so
as I was going through all the testing
and figuring out what was wrong with my
gut figuring out what was wrong with all
of my health and and so being able to
take the time and the things I'll say to
Jason is if minimalism has helped me
with with anything is it's helped me
realize that that I can let go of
anything including commitments routines
the best feeling in the world man yeah
being able let go of my habits being
able to let go of businesses or business
ideas or creative ideas or or being able
to let go of travel being able to even
let go of my identity because we get so
wrapped up in that that you know people
ask you what you do now I mean for me
I'll still say oh how I'm really
passionate about writing the only time
that I give a really concise answer to
that is when we're going through
immigration or something and they're
like what do you do I'm like okay
writer like if this is you need a
specific job title yeah you need a job
tell it says I'm on the customs form
like right job title yeah yeah and and
they're not asking so you can you know
so they can compare themselves to you in
a socio-economic ladder no they're
asking because yeah
well yeah because because because of
government overreach but they loved it
they live to steal our rights anyway
keep going the airport it's the only
proper place to steal all our rights
that's right
well we actually will talk about all of
them but a lot of it will talk about
stealing your rights during the added
value say but I think that that the
letting go for me has allowed me to
welcome room for the new or welcome the
new life so letting go of the this past
year I can look back and say it's been
great past 12 months we've been 104
flights the last 12 months Jesus and and
I don't want to fly anymore and I'd
flown a hundred and four times yeah
hundred four flights yes and so I look
back at that and I'm like oh like that's
great but I am for minimalist you guys
sure don't fly enough or whatever you
know I'm sorry insert insert you know
ironically yeah well she'll take care of
it Sean what the the the irony is real
with respect to even today like last
night I could not sleep and I'm like
trying to spend this time to recover and
we're doing an episode about resetting
and recovering and and I can't sleep
tonight and so I get up this morning at
like 3 a.m. and I but I make the best
use of that time I started doing some
physical therapy and stuff like that but
I realized I can let go of whatever that
that pass was so I can focus on the new
and the new now for me is getting back
to these basics the writing the
podcasting and and in the film and and
being able to let go of like okay that
was great chapter and that chapter is
over and I can celebrate it and I think
it's actually important during this time
of recovery so Jason was asking a
healing and well that's physical healing
but also the the emotional healing I
think it's important to pause and
celebrate and not just say all right on
to the next thing and that's what I've
been doing I've been appreciating this
this last year or especially the course
of the last week and being thankful for
it because inevitably by the end of the
tour I we're on city 48 and I'm like
alright I feel like I'm finally ready to
go on tour like everything's firing on
all cylinders now dude this Australia
tour it was the first time I felt
confident in like the talk and in doing
the live podcast I mean truly when I say
truly confident I mean like I mean I
still get a little jittery still a
little nervous yeah but I wasn't like
second-guessing every single thing I was
saying right but but to your point it
took me eight years to get there right
right and now you can look back and say
okay that chapter is is over and we've
had all these like sort of mini chapters
different tours a book comes out the
film comes out those are all different
chapters and I can I can celebrate that
and I could be thankful for it but I can
also walk away and say I'm not tethered
to that I'm not tethered to being a
writer I'm not tethered to being a
minimalist one of the minimalists like
it's something that serves me well right
now but also the ability to let go of
any of that serves me even better yeah
absolutely man when I think about the
it's funny I giving time to heal when I
think about the ways I have been able to
just feel different I I guess going with
the the word healing here the the places
in my life where I feel like I've been
healed I think first and foremost is my
confidence man like I really didn't even
think about that until until Jason
brought up this question and I'd like to
think well yeah it's because of
minimalism that helped me to detach from
things it's helped me to not care about
impressing people who I don't really
like anyway who well I shouldn't say
that I don't like but people who would
judge me off of my physical appearance
or I don't know
right in right yeah yeah it's like I
wouldn't want to have someone like that
in my life anyway like I wouldn't like
to hang around people like that so right
yeah so I mean so when my confidence I
feel like I have I'm just I don't know
I've never felt so confident man and
it's not like you know I think that I
can like take over the world or anything
as much as it is like I'm just confident
with how I'm living my life like my
short-term actions truly align with my
long-term values and beliefs and like
that is what makes me feel very very
confident I don't think I would have got
there if it wasn't for this thing called
minimalism I think the other thing too
is we were talking about this yesterday
Josh net we're doing a an interview for
a for a friend there they're filming
this documentary I really won't say
anything about it because there's no
official launch date or anything but we
were talking I was talking about
scarcity and how I at 25 years old 26
years old felt like man I just want to
be a millionaire I'm just gonna like I'm
gonna save up enough money I'm gonna be
a millionaire that I'm gonna retire
early and then I can live off of you
know let's say it's a million dollars or
three million dollars but like I never
really knew what I would do with that
money just you know a million three
million it sounded like a lot of money
and I felt like that's you know those
are the numbers or you know as long as
it has seven figures in it like that is
what is going to make it so I'm not
going to I'm not gonna face scarcity for
that I sleep enough to you at the time
right the problem is enough always
changes once you get right previously
perceived as enough you then you're
gonna want more yeah enough is never
enough when we have the wrong mindset
so now when I 50 Sean yeah it is so now
when I think about you know retirement
if I had a million dollars that'd be way
more than enough like because now I know
like I know my budget I know what it
takes to to to provide for myself I know
that scarcity is it is much further than
than what I initially anticipated right
and that to me is I mean it's just it's
the best feeling
world man like right now if the rug was
swept out from underneath of us and you
know whatever internet blew up on our
book spontaneously combusted and like we
had to go get regular jobs I would have
to move apartments because we live live
in Los Angeles but I could totally
I could totally you know move back to
Missoula and be a barista and live off
of you know a barista salary because
that is how I've set up my life and like
knowing that like I'll always be able to
find a way to make it work like that is
I don't know it's just it's a very
empowering feeling and I think scarcity
is what is what really drives people to
especially people with families because
like keys you know if I'm providing not
just for me but Mariah and then let's
say we have two kids like I really want
to make sure especially if they're
relying on me I want to make sure
they're provided for right so that that
feeling of scarcity is going to it's
just going to make me do things that I
normally wouldn't do like if you really
want to see how far someone would go
like you know you look at a single
mother who's jobless and needs to feed
her kid like that mother is gonna do
some crazy things to make sure they're
that their kid is fed and I'm just
bringing this you know to a to an
extreme point to show how scarcity makes
people act in certain ways the problem
was is that I had enough but still felt
like I didn't have enough yes that
perceived scarcity as opposed to
legitimate or just real scarcity right
and and I think that's that's quite
often the problem with our culture is we
feel like we need to accumulate more and
more and advertising does a good job of
making us feel like things are scarce
and urgent as well and I think when we
realize that what I have is enough and
it's more about what my actions are as
opposed to the things that I accumulate
that's far more impressive to me as as
an individual then like well I'm gonna
get this next new shiny thing it's more
about what can I do with the time that I
have here on earth and that's an
abundance mindset there because I've got
time to create something meaningful I
don't want to use that time to just
consume endlessly yeah Jason I'd love to
send you a copy of our book everything
that remains that is it's a memoir about
the five years of through the process of
me letting go and Ryan letting go of the
excess in our life and really
discovering the the art of having enough
so Shawn I think of reach out to Jason
send him the audiobook version of that
if you like our podcast you'll probably
like the audiobook version or if you
just want the book or the eBook version
we could send those to you as well our
next question is from Keira in Davis
California
I am an extreme introvert like Joshua I
am the IFJ on the myers-briggs and so I
really need my alone time however I am
in college and I share a room and within
a house was a total of four girls and
it's not financially feasible for me to
live on my own although that's what I
would really like to do so my question
is that given those limited
circumstances and the fact that I have a
very package schedule how would you
suggest getting the alone time that I
need and then just some background
information for you guys so obviously I
would really like to live on my own but
I can't afford that and I don't think
it's smart to go in to debt for that and
also I am a double major so I have a
pretty packed schedule I'm pre-med and
I'm also a dancer and so usually I don't
have just like blocks of time that I
could just like carve out and go
somewhere and I really do of my schedule
like I love everything that I'm doing so
I'm not really willing to give those
things up and I feel fine and filled up
when I have my long time but when I
don't it's really hard so Josh Kyra has
filled her entire schedule up she's
allocated every minute of her time to
double majors two other hobbies two
other things she lives with four
roommates mm-hmm so how does she get
more time when she's filled up all of
her time well I'd buy more watches Rolex
will buy you more time yeah I think the
lesson here is the more expensive butter
under the lightning round so Kyra you
are an infj most of the people I've ever
dated or infj so I I know your
personality type I'm an INTJ really high
on the tea and I've dated some high FS
out there and I only imagined so if you
for those you don't know what
myers-briggs is you can go
check it out there's si on our website
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
Sean it's called a loan time and there's
a link to if you want to take a
myers-briggs test online for free we
it's not our test obviously but you can
check it out anyway learning about your
personality helps you learn how to
better interact with other people I've
learned it's one of the yeah it's one of
the best things that one can do for
themselves is figuring out like what
makes them tick I mean people know what
makes them tick but it like it puts it
in a in a nice little hey here's why you
are this way and why you lean towards
certain you know certain feelings rather
than judgments yada yada yada but more
importantly yes like it totally helps
you understand yourself which when you
understand yourself well then you can
understand others as well yeah you can
understand how your personality
intertwines with other personalities
better like you and I have a pedagogical
relationship and it helps us be more
understanding of what the other person's
needs are right and so right now you
understand what your needs are Kyra but
the question is do you understand what
the other folks needs are or even better
yet do you understand how to communicate
your needs and that's why I think why
you're why you're calling in here so so
a few things that I would do if I were
in your situation I can't tell you
whether or not this will work for you
but I know what I would do were I given
your situation first off I know you say
you're doing a lot of things that
fulfill you right now that make you feel
good but sounds like you're doing too
many of those things and I can speak
from experience because last year I did
too many of those things that I said yes
for the first time my life became first
time in my life in seven years the since
the corporate world I became busy for
the first time because I said yes to
these individual opportunities it all
made sense individually but saying yes
yes yes yes yes yes means eventually I
started saying no to the things that
were truly important and so maybe you
have to say no to a few of those things
that would otherwise be yeses so you can
say well so you can say yes to yourself
right say yes to the a long time a few
things that I would do though in your
situation since you have a house full of
roommates I would treat my house my home
as a place to sleep I probably wouldn't
be spending a lot of time
there though if I have a bunch of
roommates if I need alone time home is
not the place to go for that alone time
because unless you can lock yourself in
your room but even then you're gonna
feel the anxiety and the pressure to
interact with other people while you're
home but if you're coming home when it's
time to sleep and you head straight to
bed and then you get up in the morning
you shower and and you leave the house
just becomes a place for you to to sleep
and get ready and that's that's about it
you can find a lone time and and what
you might call third spaces so you've
got school and you've got home those are
the the first your two primary spaces
but one of the places in which you can
find alone time maybe that's maybe
that's at a library maybe it's a yoga
studio maybe it's at a coffee shop maybe
it's at a park maybe it's a taking a
hike or a walk there are plenty of
places you can go and and be alone also
being alone doesn't mean you have to be
completely solo I like being around what
I would call ambient people it's like
working out of coffee shop sometimes or
out of co-working spaces because I don't
have necessarily have to interact with
other people but there's a potential for
interaction and it makes me feel like
I'm not cooped up in a room somewhere
which can be nice especially if I'm just
writing first thing in the morning I do
want to be alone with no distractions
but if I'm just working ambient people
it's great it actually fuels me a little
bit to have the potential for
interaction knowing I don't have the
requirement for interaction so having
spaces with ambient people is a
counterintuitive way for you to have
alone time and then the last thing I'll
talk about is you want to schedule some
you time first because what's happening
right now is you've already filled your
calendar I mean Ryan well if I were sure
if I looked at her calendar right now
she's got so much going on with a double
major and the dance and and all these
like extracurricular activities it's
already full and she's like where's the
time for me pre-med already sounds
overwhelming I can't imagine throwing
another major on top of it yeah I mean
it's it is something that certainly is
admirable you know I mean that's when I
about to our corporate days it was like
this badge of honor I worked 80 hours
this week and it's like it is admirable
to a certain extent when he's also sad
yeah when you could see someone was such
a such a wide bandwidth it's it's maybe
not admirable as much as like I look at
your bandwidth oh my god I wish I had
Josh's bandwidth but I would never put
myself in jeopardy my my sanity in
jeopardy to try and take on as much as
you take on well yeah it's in it's uh
it's a bit of an illusion too because
then I can look at someone like Joe
Rogan and be like how does he do comedy
four nights a week in front of live
audiences and go out on tour and do for
three-hour podcasts a week and write
daily and take care of a family and it's
like oh there are other people where
it's like they have a different
bandwidth from me and so what's
appropriate for me may not be
appropriate for Kira or you and I think
she needs to identify like look hey I
need to I need some alone time
she's already identified that now you
need to figure out where it fits first
before you schedule the classes before
you schedule the extracurricular
activities before you schedule the
dinner with friends and then you need to
prioritize the other things but
prioritize you first because getting
that alone time that you need is gonna
make you the best version of yourself
when you spend that time around other
people yeah
Kira your plate is full and you love how
full your plate is you love everything
on your plate but Kira you don't love
everything on your plate you just got
done telling us why you don't love
everything on your plate and I don't
really know Josh how to nicely say Kira
you got to take something off your plate
yeah you're you're blaming your schedule
for not having enough alone time and
you're right it is your schedule I would
love to sit here and have like a magical
piece of advice that would be like oh
yeah here's how you can get an extra
hour during the day or he's hurting
getting an extra half hour but the truth
is is there's not a simple answer no we
all have the same 24 hours in a day
yeah what's what is what's crazy or
maybe it's not crazy but in her question
she is identifying
a problem and she's saying I know the
problem here's my question how do I yeah
here's the problem here's my question
what's the problem so here's the weird
thing like the the solution is actually
in the question right yeah yeah so here
I'd love to send you a copy of our book
essential it is there's 12 chapters on
intentional living and one of those
chapters I think you'll find the most
benefit in is chapter 5 it's a chapter
on mindfulness or mindful living and
there's here's a few of the essays that
are is 150 essays in this book total but
a few of the essays that are in that
mindfulness chapter there's one called
the worst thing that could happen and
that is such an important question like
what's we always asked like what's the
worst that can happen but also ask
asking what is the best that can happen
is is a question that might change your
life we talked about decluttering your
mental clutter we we talked about
fighting the voice in your head we
talked about meditating there's a
discussion with sam harris in there
about mindfulness there's five ways to
create solitude there's an essay called
a quiet place and that essay I mentioned
alone time is also in there and there's
a few other essays that are in there
one's about overcoming self-doubt and
and just a few few essays about living
more mindfully and I think Kyra you will
find value in that book Sean I think you
reach out to her and and give her the
audiobook version of that it's our
longest book so I think it's like six
hours of audio there's one I say though
that's not in there that she really
needs to read what is that an apology
and the need to say no and it was
basically what we were talking about
earlier about how we took on too much
last year yeah and especially you took
on too much meaning that we have
different bandwidths that way yeah I'm
not as durable as you write and I look
at you and I'm like oh man I wish I I
wish that I was an ox but I used to take
that as like an insult no it's it's a
compliment it's the strongest farm
animal there is Josh Wagner
the you know Wagner for this you don't
know he's one of the mentors on my
mentoring web a wet web page
he was slate you called me he's like I
was doing like a headstand on a
paddleboard or something and this was
like 20 pounds heavier because I've lost
like 20 pounds dude since yeah since the
whole pre-diabetes diagnosis and I could
easily do a headstand on a paddleboard
and he's like you're like an ox man and
I knew what he meant but like because
I'm just insecure with my the way I look
in my body I took it as an insult but
now I take it as a compliment yeah
because I know what you're saying and
I've lost a little bit of weight so I've
got a little bit more confidence there
but no the this this essay definitely
put in the shownotes Shaun & Kyra for
you definitely read this because josh is
also an introvert and everything that we
said yes to last year it was amazing
stuff and we're really really happy we
were able to do it but it left Josh
feeling exhausted and this is an essay
about that so you're gonna enjoy it and
hopefully it helps you with your
situation I'm grateful for the past I'm
grateful for what's about to come and
this time that we have right now I feel
really grateful for it it is it is a
time for healing it's a time for me it's
a time for me so I can be the best
version of myself for other people and I
think we'll talk about that a little bit
later in the episode but first we'd love
to hear what you all have to say so if
you have a comment or a tip about
resetting or recovering or healing
including advice for any of our callers
today then leave us a voicemail at four
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm where
our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode Ryan what time is it I
don't know let me look at this fancy
Rolex I have on oh it looks like it's
time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media we do
indeed we're on Twitter Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalists during the
lightning round so Ryan and I both do
our best to each answer every question
was just a a short shareable less than
140 character response we also put the
text to these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like and now you can find all of our
quotes all in one place over at minimal
Maxim's calm I want to be very clear I
do not own a Rolex and the
only watch I own is a it's a dive
computer that I only wear when we go
diving a computer yeah it's I kept
conning the dive watch and like diet
like the the dice imagining where oh
dude it's basically that it's just
smaller than that got my laptop on my
wrist I kept calling it a tie watch and
they're like it's much smarter than a
watch and it's smarter than a smart
watch so you did buy more time
more diving time all right all right all
right come on back to the show Josh all
right our first question is from Joshua
hook
Joshua writes how can we work to
prioritize tasks that are important but
not urgent all right so this is an
important question because I think of
here's the best example I have for you
Ryan is email is the epitome of urgent
but generally not important it's urgent
for everyone else it's everyone else
dictating what our priorities are but
it's not as important as the other
things in our lives how often do you
check email once a day not even every
day I'm down maybe five times a week
especially during to where I'm down the
lake once every four or five days there
are some times I've been like a week
without it the only time I respond
because I'll see the subject and who
it's from and if it's like you know are
if it's Andrew are you know agent yeah
who needs a response then like I'll look
at it but even if I don't look at that
whole send me a tax or it'll send you
text hey I sent you an email can you
look at it so it's like people who
really need to get a hold of me if it's
urgent
yeah they've got another way to get a
hold of it right and and I think that's
the thing so so my pithy answer in the
wall we'll talk about a little bit here
what's urgent usually isn't what's
important so that's my tweetable answer
there and yeah expand on that a little
bit like you give me an example well so
the question that I often ask myself is
is this important or is it just agent
and and I think the other way to put
that as most emergencies aren't we think
of things as a
emergency's fires here the Fidel think
about when he worked in the corporate
world everything was like urgent urgent
urgent urgent but so few of those things
were actually important right what's
important to me now I have sort of
systematized into my habit so I'll give
you an example of a day in fact I'll
pull up my calendar right now and it
will go over the last day or two today
and tomorrow or yesterday so here's
here's yesterday so morning's for me I
don't even have anything on the calendar
I generally don't like to schedule
anything before noon if I can get away
with it I don't schedule anything before
2 p.m. on my calendar now the reason
being is I want to focus on my most
important habits and so I make my
important habits urgent I want them to
be both important and urgent that's how
you truly prioritize something oh I like
it and so for me my habits revolve
around my values in our first book in
fact Shawn if you reach out to Joshua
hook and send him a copy of minimalism
living meaningful life we talked about
the five values in there health
relationships creativity or passion and
then growth and contribution and my
mornings I prioritize at least two of
those values for me it's creativity and
it's health hmm so I do something I some
sort of exercise or physical therapy
every morning I got up at 3:00 this
morning and the first thing I did I
started making coffee and before the
coffee was even made I'm on the yoga mat
doing physical therapy at 3 a.m. well
the other thing I'll usually do and the
reason I started with that today is my
back was hurting a little bit this
morning and once I did that for about an
hour I started writing I've been working
on a handful of essays in fact if you
aren't on our email list you might want
to be because there's a lot of essays
there quite a few essays I'm working on
since December and they're like all
starting to come to a head now
in fact Shawn and I are working on one
the other day I'm like I'll Shawn this
is this is actually three different
essays I couldn't figure it out why it
wasn't working well it needed to be
three much shorter essays like these
these bite-sized chunks so we've got
quite a few new writings coming on the
minimalists calm but I start writing I
feel compelled to write in the morning
because it gets the it's a
I feel most alive is when I'm exercising
or I'm writing but it also sets my day
up for success I've already feel like
I've I've accomplished something through
writing for a couple hours and I feel
like I the extra set exercise for an
hour then it's like oh like everything
else on top of this is gravy now I've
gotten rid of the the important things
that aren't even on my calendar I don't
have to put these on my calendar the
first things I work on i when I when I
get up in the morning and and that's
important to me now you might have to
put those on your calendar right away so
that you can eventually turn them into a
habit but for me I work on not
scheduling anything the only exception
is when we're recording these podcasts
we tend to record them in the mornings
but on days that we're not recording
podcast I try to schedule anything until
afternoon so if I look at my calendar
right now Ryan mm-hmm
yesterday for example I had 10 a.m.
clean the house so that was after
writing and exercising yesterday morning
and at 11:30 I had lunch with a friend
and 1:30 you and I had a media interview
that we had to do at 4 o'clock I had a
phone call about our taxes at 5 o'clock
I had to prepare for this episode
episode 128 and that was it that's what
I had scheduled for the day so those are
the things that were most important that
I had to make urgent for the day and
then you know today I have you know
something similar today I've got we're
doing recording this podcast you and I
are doing our friend Joshua Weaver who
owns a coffee shop with us he's in town
he's going to do some photos with us I
got some taxes stuff that I need to do
at 2 o'clock and then we have dinner a
business meeting at 5 o'clock and oh and
at at here's here's something I have at
2:00 p.m. I just have scheduled their
taxes and email like I know out there I
have a bunch of emails I haven't
responded to I need it to get to right
and so for me here's the order I have my
habits in the morning I have my calendar
that runs the day and then when there's
free space I have a to-do list not this
might help you out Ryan I don't know I
help Jessica out a lot when we were over
in Australia Jessica who does our social
media she was asking me about sort of my
workflow like how do I keep things
organized
and for me I just use a Apple notes and
I have two different notes I have a one
note I'm looking at right now it says
today right and then I have another note
that says someday right and on my two
day list I list everything that I need
to do today these are tasks whenever I
get a free moment these are things that
I should be working on and so like it
says prep from episode 128 I can cross
it off because we already did that I
need to respond to a rich role he texted
me last night I need to respond to our
friend drew he texted me last night and
I need to update a few of these these
things on our website so like there's a
few things I need to do today and then
right below that it says tomorrow and
there are a few things I need to do I
need to buy some paper towels and dish
soap and bleach I think in body bags and
rubber gloves and shovels and I need to
order some coffee filters like that's on
my list for tomorrow so if you look at
this as today tomorrow and then it says
this week and as I accomplish things
they work their way up toward today so
the things that are on my list for
tomorrow will be on today's list
tomorrow right and are the things that
are on this week's list will eventually
move their way up and then I have this
separate some day list where it's like I
really would need to work on this
business idea or I need to you know
whatever I want to buy concert tickets
for this thing but I don't want to deal
with that this week and so I have the
some day list that of things that I know
here's another way to look at it not
urgent list my Sunday list is like ah
these aren't urgent my today list is man
these are things that are urgent so I
sort of have an urgent list by default
the today list and it's really this weak
list and then the some day list not
urgent but there are things I know I
want to do here's the cool thing about
both of these lists whenever I look at
them after I'm done writing or
exercising the more I look at these
lists qualifies them over across a few
things off immediately like sometimes
just because the thing happened without
me planning it so I have called Jerome
my brother he called me last night and
so I this is on my list to do this week
I can delete it right now because I've
already talked to him and that's done
right it's off the list and there are
other things where it's like oh yeah
that was kind of important but the time
has passed I didn't have time for
and sound now it's not urgent anymore I
can let that go
yeah so I prioritize urgent and not
urgent and that that's what helps me out
a lot Ryan what about you yeah I think
the calendar thing it leads directly to
what I was gonna say so much tweetable
answer is this when it comes to
prioritizing calendar is king
procrastination is the enemy so here's
the thing is we all procrastinate a
little bit like your tomorrows list of
things that's going to you know move
their way up to eventually today right
that is a form of I think it's a form of
procrastination am I wrong on that yeah
you are but that's okay I understand
what you're saying yes so okay so help
help me in the the listeners here
differentiate how is that different from
progressives so procrastination means
putting it off because I I don't want to
deal with it it's the the fear thing you
were talking about earlier the scarcity
thing right it's fear of doing this Oh
procrastinating we would mean putting
off the important thing to actually deal
with something that's less urgent so
procrastinating we would be browsing
Facebook instead of writing it would be
ah let me open up Twitter before I do
that let me scroll through Instagram
putting out of reading this makes it so
procrastination we can we can agree that
it's putting something ahead of putting
something ahead of another thing that is
more important exact that you're scared
to deal exactly so so so that does stand
true then calendars king of
procrastination is the enemy absolutely
so what I would say for me yeah if it's
not on my calendar it's probably not
gonna get done if I leave and and I just
and I still am guilty of doing this but
I will do it less and less like I'll
leave some articles in my inbox
someone's like hey Ryan you need to read
this here Ryan listen to this podcast
here I need you to check out this book
hey writing it and I do I appreciate all
the recommendations um I will never get
through all the recommendations right
and I give myself about a week of it
being in my inbox and if I haven't got
to it then I'll delete it yeah you have
to let it go yeah it's it's it's not
gonna it's not gonna drive me crazy
I keep the recommendations coming I love
them
I get to about 1% of them and that's
okay but if I I've met
people who have come to our events and
they've got a member the one dude who he
had all the articles saved he'd like 600
or 800 like links and his favorites that
he was saving to read one day and I'm
like dude you're never gonna read 800
articles I was like just delete them all
right now
and he did and he was like god I feel so
good but but I mean all I did was give
him permission to like let go of all
these bookmarks to me that he was never
gonna get back to so so I'm glad you
said that so when I when I talked about
the the today list yeah I have more
stuff about today list this week because
it's like catching up kind of stuff sure
then I ever have but for me a lot of
times I try to get that to nothing I
want nothing on my today list I want
nothing on my calendar right because
then it's focusing only on my values in
my habits right and so if I have nothing
on my calendar I know the default for me
is I need to be focusing on creativity
or relationships or contribution and
then of course I will give myself
permission to then pacify myself without
procrastinating because if I've done
everything else then it's great it's not
procrastination anymore it's like it's a
little room time to relax yeah yeah man
no I totally agree I mean for me the
calendar is huge I wish I was a little
bit more organized like like you've been
it and that well it my list that you're
talking yeah sounds great so I'm showing
it to Ryan right now this is what I what
I did for Jes so this is my list it just
says today tomorrow this week that's all
one note and as I check them off they
just disappear there they're gone they
delete them I don't put them somewhere
else and say oh I accomplished that and
check the box no no I wasn't deleted
that's my I want a gun just like you did
with the guy who came to our event
delete all of it and so sometimes I can
go to some mornings I can go in here and
say alright that's actually not
important delete delete delete and then
my Sunday list just has like oh here are
the things I need to work on someday
right I it's it's the if I don't want
these to get in the way of what I needed
to do today though but I know I want to
work on an event I do have a folder in
my in my email it's labeled
and it's all in caps it's a label with
interesting things to do
ah and what it is it's like I just put
something in there this morning I was I
was in a case it's called the gorge it's
in Kentucky I think it's called the
gorge I think I'm referring to that
place right or maybe it's just gorgeous
Gorge Kentucky I have no idea anyway my
buddy was getting married down there and
his mom she has a she's got this program
that is all around the date March 4th
and it's all about like marching forth
with with with your life and it's like
her day the lake just it's it's really
in her it's really an interesting
concept like she just kind of looks at
how the last year went it's kind of her
like New Year's I guess okay um if you
want to look at it that way I don't want
to get too much into it cuz I haven't
read on it yet but it is something
that's really interesting to me and she
sent me the course it's a good time to
reset right and she sent me this course
and it's great like I'm not gonna have
time to look at that this week or maybe
even the rest of this month uh-huh
but I guess that's my that is my someday
that's my someday folder where it's like
if I if I'm looking for time to come
like oh yeah there are those interesting
things I wanted to look at like I'll go
to that and take a look at it oh and by
the way if my someday folder gets longer
than a page like if I have to scroll
then I have started deleting stuff yeah
at least uh yeah but only got like five
things and that interesting things to do
but to your point I should probably have
a little a little marker on how many is
too many
so just sum it up for Joshua hook real
quick I I deal with my habits first my
calendar second and then my today list
third those are the things that's how I
prioritize and make sure that only the
important things end up in those places
and then when there's free time then I
can work on the things that are less
important smith royce writes in how can
a minimalist stay a minimalist in a non
minimalist environment i live in india
and most of the people here including my
family haven't heard of minimalism or
anything like it and that keeps me from
being a minimalist Oh Smith Royce man
you know what my problem is everyone
else too
That's not me at all you know you know
my problem is it's you Josh it's you
podcast Sean and it's anyone else in my
life yeah here's my short answer for for
Smith and I'll keep it short period here
is even a great excuse is still an
excuse right I mean I think most
minimalist live among countless non
minimalists including me and Ryan we
live among a bunch bunch of middle
listen by the way I live here in America
and most people haven't heard of
minimalism here either and just because
someone else in your household isn't a
minimalist doesn't mean that you can't
be a other people in my house eat bread
doesn't mean I have to eat bread too
right other people in my house he bread
means I have to eat bread yeah I mean
even if they're passionate about bread
you can still support their passion
without you eating bread exactly so I
want one recommendation Shawn put a link
to this in the show notes
Matthew fella just put out a video about
minimalist living with a non minimalist
living with his partner Natalie and it's
a funny video it's it's on his youtube
channel we'll put a link to that in the
show notes Ryan he's got a lot of funny
videos it's it's a good it's a good
YouTube channel in general I've got a
I've got a couple different answers well
here's the first answer a person who
blames others for their discontentment
will always rely on others for
contentment has such a problem that is a
problem man because well I'll just go
into the second answer it might I was
having a conversation with my mom when
we were just in Ohio and she said
something just really profound that I
I've well mainly my mom has made some
major changes over the last year two
years but I just never thought that I
that her she would have this perspective
but what she said was that she was like
if you have to wait for another to
change their life in order for your life
to get better you're fighting a losing
battle
yeah and it's so true man like if I had
to wait around for everyone else to
become a minimalist before I became a
minimalist I would never become a
minimalist and this is the same exact
situation s pithy answer right
yeah just you can put that one in there
Shawn we got 350 answers there um but
Smith Royce the that is it's just an
excuse and you can we're not saying that
you can or cannot use that excuse you
can do whatever you want but it is just
an excuse the way that you start
becoming a minimalist as you start you
start acting in alignment with with what
your version of minimalism looks like
and your friends and family hopefully
they will support you and if you go out
here if you go way out of I was just
having a conversation with the mentee
yesterday if someone goes way out of
their way to to not support you [ __ ]
them
like there is no reason to ever to ever
keep someone in your life who goes out
of their way to tear you down man so
Smith Royce if you got friends and
family who you you you've you've gone to
and and you say hey look like I really
appreciate the way you guys live and and
I love you and I want to support you and
I want to live this way and I really
hope that you can appreciate that and
you can support me and they're not gonna
reciprocate that same appreciation and
support then then you got to find
different people to hang out with that
doesn't mean to like just turn your back
on your family but your obligation to
your family at that point is to be nice
to them at family gatherings that's it
yeah yeah and sometimes being nice means
not having to interact with them that
much at all yeah and so yeah start with
yourself Smith and and you don't even
have to start diving into minimalism
just simplify a little bit and you'll
find some contentment in that and who
knows other people might start finding
contentment in what you're doing and
they might follow you in that process of
simplifying we've got one more question
here from Anna Anna says how do you cope
with getting back into the swing of busy
work life after taking time off I
usually find it hard reading up on the
news after taking time away from my
phone and to get the answer to that
question you'll have to tune in to our
PostScript episode each week Ryan and I
record a PostScript episode for the
minimalist private podcast it's a
separate separate podcast feed
exclusively for our patreon supporters
our patreon supporters help us keep this
podcast
percent advertisement free and we're
actually doing a bunch of new cool
things over on that feed so it shows up
in your phone just like this podcast
does but it's a separate private feed so
you'll see the minimalist podcast and
right there you'll see the minimalists
private podcast each week we have a
postscript episode where we answer our
question or two or three but then we're
also doing some really cool stuff on
Saturdays this month April and also in
May we're releasing we have this backlog
of ask the minimalists anything audio
files that we haven't published so I
think we have four or five maybe even
six episodes I've asked the minimalists
anything that we haven't put out there
yet and so it's one of my favorite
things to do because we just kind of let
our hair down and we have a lot of fun
with these live interactions we also
each month to ask the minimalist
anything live stream a video live stream
and we're also going to do a tour of
this new studio space we're in right now
we're going to do that hopefully within
the next month or so once we have
everything in working order and then
lastly the live events we have a bunch
of live events in the can we're gonna
put out one of those a month we've
already released Philly and Tampa and
Detroit and Washington DC is coming this
month as well and then I think we're
gonna do Sydney next month so a lot of
good recordings there and if you are a
patreon supporter not only do you get
any of the new stuff we put out but you
have access to the entire back catalogue
so if you want to support the podcast
just head on over to the minimalists
comm click donate at the top and become
a patreon supporter get access to all
the back catalog and all future private
podcasts all right let's move on real
quick right into our added-value portion
of the shows where we each talk about
something that has added value to our
lives
recently Ryan there was something I want
to tell you on the phone because you
said something during our Sivir
the event we had with Derek's over so
just the previous podcast episode that
came out he said like one of your
greatest fears is that people think that
we're Jesus Christ well dude sometimes
we I get that look man
what do you mean like we'll be it will
be at an event and it's like people some
people just and very few it's not it's
not often
but Lake they look like we're a lien or
something look at this like what's
admiration yeah it's the same way we're
not when I look at someone like Matt
Kearney or John Mayer or something I
think it's a type of admiration yeah it
might be I guess I guess really when I
say that what when I say that what I
mean is
we're fallible yeah we're human we don't
have well we have all the answers but
they're not all right answers yeah and
and and I just I really I really like
how with the vast majority 99.999% of
our audience like we're able to connect
with because I think that they they
can't look at us and be like all right
these guys you know they've got some
great insights but they don't take us
that seriously just like we don't take
ourselves that seriously my favorite
compliment is when someone comes up to
us and they're like you know I really
agree with half of what you say and I
love that because it's like oh awesome
like you are you're forming your own
opinions and we're and we're helping you
form those opinions yeah
and I really feel honored to be able to
help people form their opinions my my
fear is that people will just try and
have exactly the same opinion of us with
every single thing which I would do
possible because we have different
opinions on things yeah yeah we I agree
with half what you say I'm like is it my
half Araya you see what I'm saying I
don't know I don't think that people
really will look at us and expect us to
turn water into wine no but here's
here's why I brought that up and it's
because I have three recommendations one
it's a movie a TV series and a
documentary series and they all sort of
deal with this but the other side of it
in a way and there are three beautiful
pieces of art and dare I say
masterpieces that I've been able to
experience while sort of healing or
recovering or reset it taking this time
to reset has also meant taking more time
to do nothing to to also I just calm
down and and either read I've been
reading a lot more or watch a few things
that I find meaningful there's a movie I
watched on the plane while we were
flying in Australia it was called E
schools I talked to you and Mariah about
it recently but it's sort of a love
story but it takes place in in a utopian
future
but every utopia is actually just a
dystopia when it comes down to it in
order to become a utopia it seems pretty
dystopian actually but it was a it was a
sort of love story and I'm kind of
allergic to love stories but this one
was like it made me appreciate the
relationship I'm in so much Kristen
Stewart's in it yeah yeah and you don't
have one degree of separation with
acting in a movie with her oh yeah cuz
you were in a play
I was in a play with a girl named Lilly
Gladstone who did a movie with Kristen
Stewart that movie was called so you
could practically say that I've won an
Oscar I tell people that you've won an
Oscar it's a who's your best friend of
yeah have you heard of Kristen Stewart
[Laughter]
I'm sorry really oh really your
added-value
you heard a little movie called Twilight
[Laughter]
yeah so she's in this movie called
equals and it's beautifully shot and
it's like aggressively minimalist and
the the architecture and the set and
it's beautiful but there's also like
this humanity that is missing from from
it and you'll see why the movie I want
to give any spoilers but if you want to
better appreciate the people especially
your significant other in your life for
me this was a movie that just made me
like just just be thankful for the
people I have in my life the second
thing I want to talk about is and I
think this is my favorite of the three
the TV series waco mmm you know about
Waco yeah Waco Texas right yeah and and
what was a 93 I would love to see like
they did like a documentary on it a
while ago but it was this was so good it
felt like a documentary there was no
there was no interviews or anything like
it oh I shouldn't say that anyway long
story short it wasn't the best
documentary ever seen this is this was a
masterpiece this is without a doubt a
masterpiece and who was the guy who
played a Taylor Taylor
kitch he was in Friday Night Lights and
much other places he was in the second
season I'm sure detective but it was
like he was meant to be David Koresh and
like he was born to become an actor who
would play eventually play David Koresh
and the reason I brought up the the the
Jesus thing and being afraid of that
like I'm also fascinated by like when
people take the wrong path and and you
have someone like David Koresh who was
clearly charismatic and influential and
I think he bought into his own [ __ ]
right way I feel like he really believed
like his his cult was he made everyone
abstain from sex because he believed it
got in the way of of enlightenment or
living you more deliberately living a
more meaningful life and and so he took
on the burden of sex for the entire call
I think my goal is to just have a point
where like Mariah and I could just have
sex all day long right and that's a
truly meaningful life well he took on
the burden never worry about anything
else
he took the burden of sex on for the
entire call so he decided he was the
only one who was gonna have sex with all
the women for procreation and he's so
giving well yes but there's this part in
there where like he is having sex with
one of the wives and he like stops mid
mid you know sex like pre orgasm and
he's she's like what why are you
stopping and he's like because I was
beginning to enjoy it and like you could
tell like he actually I think he really
bought into all all the BS but you also
you also realize like the whole thing is
messed up as as the Branch Davidians
were like and they were cultish they
weren't actually doing anything wrong I
mean Koresh was but the rest of them
like what were they doing anything legal
that's no they weren't and that and that
that's that and then when I said wrong I
mean yeah they weren't doing anything
illegal and it was it to me this this
this TV series which I think you can get
on I got on iTunes it was a portrait of
bureaucratic government overreaching and
overstepping their bounds just to make
sure their bureaucracy continued it was
during the Clinton administration when
the 8th
F was being defunded a little bit and
they're like we have to justify show
people why we're so important let's find
a high-profile place to go raid and that
led to what devolved and this thing is
so compelling because you know the
ending you know what's going to happen
right but you want to keep watching it
even though you know the ending every
moment of this thing is so compelling
and the guy a Taylor Kitsch who plays
they have a Koresh I mean oh my goodness
like you understand why people follow
David Koresh when you when you watch
this thing and the third thing I
recommend is a documentary series it is
possibly the best documentary I've ever
seen it see this was something that or
access through the gift shop and Matt
and I have been taught Matt the director
of our documentary and I have been
talking about six-part series is
probably bout seven hours long total but
it feels condensed like it it feels like
there isn't an extra moment but it is so
well edited and the interviews are so
well stitched together it's called wild
wild country have you heard of this do
you know who Osho was no clue he was a
guru in the mid 80s from India and they
sort of accidentally started a religion
is this this is on Netflix it is on
Netflix and someone else was telling me
about this and so they they had this
what people would call a cult I actually
don't think I would call it a cult and
there's a few reasons I wouldn't and I
certainly it's the opposite of sort of
the Branch Davidians it's not a place I
think I would have wanted to be but it
was like free sex and and but it was a
community with no vibe you paying for
sex right now well don't we all free in
the sense that I free spirited Oh free
sorry did sex yeah yeah well and and and
and the the idea is behind the community
were so antithetical so they started
this they started a city in Oregon and
in the middle of Oregon and it was it
was another example of weird government
overreach now there were it was also an
example both of these Waco and and wild
wild country were examples of when
people go into power how the Powe
or corrupt Osho I don't think was that
corrupted I I don't find a whole lot of
value and his teachings or whatever and
I thought it was silly how many Rolls
Royces and stuff he owned although I
think in a way he like had transcended
materialism and but he owned Rolexes and
Rolls Royces I think none of that stuff
matter to him like I think he was
showing that you could coexist with
materialism but it didn't really matter
to you he also has this weird stare that
I've heard Sam Harris write and talk
about it's like puts people in a trance
it's one of those stairs where he looks
at you and is able to talk to you and
and not break eye contact but know what
he had these eyes that were Saudi it's
the opposite of me because I can't keep
eye contact and saved my life I'm
looking right now this is the most
iconic kept in my life but he he had
this debilitating stare and but there it
was this community where thousands of
people found value they built their own
city they were independent it was true
independence and the government sort of
stepped in and and demonized them
because they were different it was but
he also like they had the person he left
in charge started a religion in his name
oh good grief and he he he said this is
the he like got rid of her and he said
this is the first time that we've had
that the world has ever gotten rid of a
religion because I'm not your leader
you're not my followers I don't want a
religion I don't believe in religion and
it was really powerful profound but the
way this thing was edited it's perfect
man it was a perfect documentary series
it made me look at that and say wow like
this is what is possible so if you check
these out I know it's a long-winded
answer but I have found so much value in
these three creations gave me ten hours
of stuff to watch yeah for back yea
report back and thank me later
I'll put that in my yeah I'll put it in
my uh and my interesting things to do no
it does sound really awesome and I well
I just there's another cult movie out
there I think it's called Kumari yeah
it's Kumari and it's about this guy who
basically starts a cult as like a
it's a social experiment to show hey
here's how you can start a cult and even
though I know it's complete bull like an
instruction manual yeah I'm gonna show
you how you can start a cult and how you
can get other people to follow all you
have to do is you know and then it goes
through how he forms his cult right it
does like it it really goes in a
direction I never thought before they
are not taught before but thought before
I watched the film that didn't you know
I had an idea of where this film was
leading mm-hmm and it just blew my mind
how just how valuable the perspective
was on on this fake cult that he started
and then however because he eventually
reveals that hey guys this is a fake
call I totally started it I pull all
this out of my ass and did they not
believe him I don't want to do any
spoiler alerts but because it's like
what you reminded me I was really in
Fight Club where like yeah the nameless
character comes to his senses and he's
like I'm you know I'm not telling you
told us you'd say that yeah no it's it's
it's it's an interesting movie um no I I
love I find those things really
interesting religion interesting
specifically um man you know just going
back before I go on to my added value I
thought of uh recently this was an
Australian someone came up to me and
they were looking at me like I was an
alien you know they're like oh you're
Ryan Nicodemus the minimalists like oh
man you know I love your podcasts and
like first off like I'm so uncomfortable
with like saying because what someone
comes over to me they're like dude you
saved my life and a nice look at him I
go hip Thanks like I mean it just feels
like such a such a crappy way to like to
say there to show them how appreciative
I am of where there's an inner support
there's an imbalance there that's hard
to make up for that right yeah because I
don't want to be like this you're right
I of course I hope you saved your life
and I don't want to just say thanks like
there's a balance in between those two
things right that I just haven't
mastered yet uh-huh
butBut regardless she said something
about and I could just tell like she was
kind of looking at like oh like you're
the minimalist guy like you're one of
the minimalist guys and I said something
along the lines of I said well hey um
you know just so you know I'm still
trying to be a good minimalist like I'm
not there yet and I'll never get there
and she was like you're joking right she
was like I that would scare me if that's
true like you're not a minimalist yet
and I'm like oh and I just brushed it
off I was like okay she's not getting
she's not getting what I'm saying that's
okay
but that's exactly what I'm talking
about when people they expect this
perfection
yeah pedestal mentality yeah yeah I was
watching Maher and I like if we're bored
like we'll put on Seinfeld or the office
or like something that like we if we got
20 minutes to kill him we want to just
sit there and cuddle on the couch like
we'll you know turn one of these things
on in the office like it was there's an
episode where long story short there was
a wedding one of the people went up to
what one of the members of the wedding
and and she was you know pleading saying
something like well you know I know I'm
not perfect and and that's okay because
nobody's perfect right and this woman
looks at this person trying to you know
get their acceptance there looks at her
and says well I wouldn't care to live if
I thought that it's just that's the
mentality that I'm scared of yes my so
I've got have we've been talking about a
lot about coffee I feel like in the last
10 or 20 episodes or at least I have
been that's good because Joshua Weaver
is downstairs right now waiting on
waiting for us yeah yeah my added-value
is basically my coffee kit I've got
people that people have been asking me
about my grinder about what kind of pour
over I use what kind of kettle I use I'm
just gonna put it all here in the show
notes so if you're interested in what I
use at home this is not my travel kit
this is what I use at home so grind dry
I use tender personally you you personal
preferences man yeah yeah your
preferences are Josh I support your
preference adds value to your life may
not add value to mine as we say all
right let's move on to actually we're
gonna do coffee crawl this weekend I'm
really excited about that good
Weaver knows all the best shops to go to
around yeah I love how he lives in
Florida and knows knows more about
coffee in LA than we do whenever we go
to a city I'm like hey we're gonna be in
Adelaide Australia where should I go
he's like here the seven places I'd
recommend yeah so we get to hang out
with him I wished Saros with him to his
wife but someone has to hold down the
fort it can't let all of the the animals
run the zoo right but let's move on to
right here right now it's where we talk
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalists already talked about the
video podcast that's coming soon once we
get to enough patreon supporters
youtube.com slash the minimalist you can
subscribe to that also since we're
talking about resetting today Ryan my
partner Rebecca she runs a website
called minimal wellness and about once a
quarter she does a 23 day reset for
people to priorities reset helping
people identify and reset their
priorities over a 23 day period she has
only 30 seats because she does
one-on-one mentoring with them in
addition to daily videos and and
different emails and things that she
sends out so she does a daily video for
folks she also does a weekly live stream
and she does she does some one-on-one
coaching with with people as well so
that's limited to 30 people I think
there are still some seats left for the
May reset so you can go to minimal
wellness comm and you can check that out
also a bunch of new essays coming to the
website make sure you're on our email
list if you want to receive those also
you'll get the show notes that show up
in your inbox every time we put out a
new podcast episode you hear me
constantly saying hey Sean puts out the
show no it's a ryan saying you'll find
that in the show notes
well we email those right to you and
we'll never ever send you any spam
because spam is disgusting Ryan you got
anything else for us finally here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners hey guys my name is aria
calling from Boston Massachusetts and I
just wanted to recommend an application
for your computer for disciplining
yourself and preventing you from
pacifying yourself and distracting
social media platforms it's called self
control and what it does is you create a
list of websites
you don't want to visit that you want to
avoid for a certain period of time you
add it to this list and set a timer and
once you set that timer whatever
internet browser you're using it won't
allow you to visit these websites until
that timer is up hi my name is Diane and
I'm calling from the San Francisco Bay
Area and I just finished listening to
your media episode and I loved it I've
been researching interviewing and
writing about the components of a
meaningful life for over a decade and
that just hit so many points of what
I've been thinking about lately with my
own work I'm a hospice volunteer and one
of the greatest privileges of my life is
sitting with people during their final
days and just listening to their stories
it's such a privilege and I think I
might approach meaning from a slightly
different perspective than the two of
you but when I found your podcast a few
months ago I was totally hooked I enjoy
them all but this recent one about media
it's just really got me sitting here
thinking and I actually stopped
exercising and deleted all the social
media apps off my phone while I was
listening to you both delete yours as if
like I was doing it at the same time as
if it was alive or something but mine
are all deleted too but I wanted to say
a couple things in regard to that
episode on one of them ID I have four
teenagers it's something that worked
with my daughter and several other
teenagers that I know because I noticed
them comparing themselves to the people
on what I call fake a book and there are
perfect bodies and perfect lives and
boyfriends and everybody just feeling
like the other person is having so much
more fun so I asked the kids you know
are these really your friends and or
even how do you define a friend and lots
of them have thousands of friends and so
what I do is I challenge them to sit
with me and go through their list of
friends and delete anyone that they
can't give me at least two facts about
how did you meet where do they go to
school where do they live anything I'm
always surprised by how many kids can't
even give me two facts
then they're always surprised when they
go through this process on their list of
biggest fake books Facebook see I can't
even say it friends list custom house so
my suggestion is just to try to ask
their teenagers to delete every one they
can't give at least two facts about and
then my suggestion is that we set aside
one day a year and call it national
deletion day or something like that
where everyone goes online and does the
exact same thing that you guys did a
massive deletion from their social media
list of friends and people they're
following who they know nothing about I
would just love to see how many
imaginary relationships could end in one
single day hi this is Shelly Lippmann
and I'm from Windsor Connecticut I had a
thought regarding shredding there's a
lot of people who don't want to purchase
a shredder but all of a sudden they'll
be cleaning out and they have a lot of
shredding to do so here's a couple of
ideas the first one is to call your
local bank a lot of them will offer free
shred days and you don't have to belong
to that bank to take advantage of that
if you don't want to hold on to the
shredding into a bank has a free shred
day the other option is to call places
like Easter Seals who work with people
with disabilities a lot of them will
have shredding operations and for a
pretty reasonable fee will shred all of
your stuff and the money goes back to
Easter Seals and it offers you know
employment for people who have
disabilities all right Joe that's it for
this episode if you have a question for
the minimalists give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm and if
you leave here with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
then minimus --tz--